hello Hi how are you good we're just
coming home like we just had like a
brunch and hung out okay yeah I was
checking to see where his hands
were you good over there okay everybody
have IDs on them
yeah yeah we're just like
from like hanging like we were at um
that
where well we were where y coming from
right now we were coming from um The
Blind Pig like doing a a brunch where
she works like a oh she works there yeah
yes sir okay can I get your ID yeah I
have mine I don't know if you want right
now she works there and we had a baby
shower like
Dora do you know Dora I don't know Dora
where's your car ke at
um in my first but it's like a push
start where's your car key at though um
in here okay can you take it out for me
please of course right here all right
thank you I'm just going to sit it right
here okay
course let's hang tight for
me all right so I'll be back with in a
minute I don't know if I told you why I
stopped you but I stopped you because
you were failing to maintain Lane okay
you were in and out of your lane about
at least about six times if not more
than that before I even stopped you
before I even turned my uh lights on
behind you um you had anything to drink
today no nothing I mean we went to Bruns
and we were 24 like we were fine we went
to brunch like we literally went to one
of our co-workers house like she had a
baby shower and we had like a mimosa
that's it and like I was just like
playing music and and we were all
hanging out and I was just driving them
back like literally their house
is and I
live my H why didn't you stop when I was
telling you to stop what why didn't you
stop when I was telling you to stop I
literally had to come up oh well I
didn't like I I had the music on because
we were were like trying like I didn't
like I was just playing did you see me
behind you um when yes I did okay so
what should you do when you see blue
lights behind you so then I sto oh you
didn't stop until I came up and I was
literally sorry about that because I
didn't like okay so my question was what
do you do when blue lights are behind
you you stopped okay yes sir so why
didn't you stop when the blue lights
were behind you um I I didn't notice I'm
sorry sir okay can you roll down the
back window yeah or maybe I don't know
if you'll be able to roll it down now
that the key is out I got the key back
there so don't worry about it oh well no
if you want to open it up open it up no
that that's fine we'll leave it like
that for right now if you would take
your seat belt off and yes sir I just
want you to just come step out of the
car for me yes
sir all right just St right there for me
yes
sir sorry about that like I
just
uh let me see if you can sit on the no
open it I can open it
okay highspeed chases we got a unruly
suspects I will kill that mother T me no
do it stay in the BL box I like K
dramatic DUI I'mma pass everything that
she trying to do and shocking body cam
footage hey get on the ground get on the
Ground lawn crime presents body cam the
place for real raw and wild police
videos you should have seen it it was
good it's on body camera I'll show it to
you catch the action and subscribe to
our new YouTube channel
[Music]
now if you would just just rest up
against the car right here yeah yeah
just have a seat there if you don't mind
okay thank
you all
right where you guys coming coming from
oh I like
literally we went to a baby shower baby
shower
literally not too um excited
honestly
but how was your Sunday sweaty I know
it's like I work
at and like it was so hot like we leave
like the back door open right and like
um I worked yesterday was like like you
can tell that it's
definitely like I kind of bitched about
it being so cold oh yeah yeah but then
it gets like I forget how hot it is y
but it really does get really hot
yeah there goes the
what that that's kind of scary they do
it all the time really
[Applause]
yeah they do that like all the
time did they not get like in trouble
all the time we catch them but you can't
really catch
them that's so crazy yeah there's only
so much you can do exactly
like it's like one of those things is
like you
can you can do
this oh you're good sit right
there yeah you can only do so much it's
like but like when they're doing that oh
they can hit the dirt trails and stuff
like that hit some pedest on the that's
what's gonna happen to him sooner or
later like I literally like I had
someone that I went to high school with
it's really sad his name
was so
I'm my parents
are but who is in the back what who's in
the back seat no one
he's just in there looking no there's
somebody back
here yeah you just hang on back here
okay who's
that yeah oh that's my friend I think
they put her back
there dude just shut up like
sh but yeah so my dad
like always does that but like it's like
kind of scary to see like how people
react on the road because he does a lot
of like like he Ridley stuff like that
it's like really kind of like
scary I'm like
always yep I had a buddy lose his leg
really somebody hit him right on the
side of the motorcycle it's like SPI and
that's what I always tell my dad because
not what going
just stay hey ma'am ma' ma'am oh oh
sorry just stop
LNA L shut up shut up dude just come up
here and stand with him D remember the
last time I had a are you doing shut
up this is
not and I got
I'm
do
huh just hold
on the beer whose beer is on the back on
the floor that what who beer is a
beer oh like just to the house these
beer are these on let me look oh yeah
that was to take to my house who me is
it yours yeah to take to my
house I'm just asking MO yeah that's
mine but they're not
open I went to the grocery
store so those are my friends like my
husband's at the house
right like those are that's my best
friend I'm just saying and when that's
her friend the guy
yeah they're not married but my husband
is legit at the
house like at
my
like
just
I don't
know they're
arguing I don't know that will
that I don't have no
clue
nothing
so it was baby shower was
it and I used to work there for years
and then long story short short I work
at have you seen that drive it's right
by
like yeah I'm a hairstylist there but so
I used to work for like years right um
and so they're really good to me
like like he's the owner of all of that
he's really awesome really good um is
one of my best friends um she's a
manager yeah I got
mhm um so and then Dora takes over all
the books and all of that so we had a
baby okay so like where does he work uh
he
worked um where like something happens
with the equipment he needs to fix it
okay okay like he's kind of like on
standby if like something goes wrong
okay but that's I mean I love
her I'm trying to see
yep there white little bugs all
around
huh
sounding
there's hardly anybody
out so there's hardly anybody out
doesn't
matter what you
need hold on one second
okay
[Applause]
hello hi hey how are you good how are
you good I'm off your awesome wanted to
get his Vape out of the front I told him
to wait get his what Vape I went to a
baby shower like legit like got okay
would you be okay to do some f spry
exercises and make sure I will but I
won't blow okay that's fine yeah okay
cool uh you might if I take a look at
your eyes yeah okay do you wear contacts
or glasses I do wear glasses you wear
glasses are they required for you to
drive um going to hit me up for that I
mean it's
like7 whatever does that matter no no no
give me just a second I'm just to make
sure everybody turn I like canot see far
away okay okay that's the
thing up close I can you see up close
yeah yeah but like far away like really
far yeah yeah yeah you
oh is that bad just say huh
you want me to turn them
off they're backwards oh no they're not
they're front yeah you hit the back for
the front to turn
off they wired it wrong no they didn't
they did that's how it's supposed to be
right no like if you H the front the
front's supposed to turn on hey I
wouldn't have known if they were
supposed to do yeah yeah
okay so if you don't mind like standing
like right here facing towards me and
you put your feet together arms down to
your side all
right got to catch my breath I've been
doing too much walking today all right
I've done a lot of cardio today to it's
like brutal gotcha so I'm going to
illuminate this red stylus I just need
to follow it with your eyes and your
eyes only I'm going to move it around
just don't move your head okay so you're
just going to track it with your
eyeballs gotcha
okay just make sure you're following
that with your eyes
okay
you looking at
it way over there my eyes are dry as
hell I guess you can blink as much as
you need to oh my God okay we want to
thank Morgan and Morgan for sponsoring
this body cam video I mean I think it's
pretty clear from the body cam that we
cover that it's not always safe out
there when you're hurt it can be
confusing it can be scary you don't
really know where to turn well Morgan
and Morgan is actually the largest
injury law firm in America and in a time
when you already have so much to think
about they're going to make it super
easy for you they have completely
modernized the process because you
submit your claim you sign contracts you
upload documents you talk to your whole
legal Team all on your phone that's it
an attorney is going to review your case
in just eight
also they have 4,000 support staff that
can help you too which is just amazing
to think about and in terms of price
well you only pay them if you win
there's no upfront fee so if you're
injured and you want to join the over 3
million people that call them every year
you can submit a claim at www.
forthepeople.com
LC bodycam or by dialing pound law
that's pound 529 on your phone it's like
really over there
left
all right same thing just up and down
okay
[Music]
all
right why is it my eyes so dry what's up
my eyes are dry oh I got you all right
so go ahead and turn this way and just
go ahead and put your feet together arms
down to your side for me I'm going to
stand this way just so I can demonstrate
for you okay I made you go along the
hill that way we're not going down and
up the hill that way you can have some
better chance of walking okay so what
we're going to do is just listen to
every instruction I give you real close
carefully okay don't start until I tell
you to begin and uh after You' started
don't stop okay so what I'm going to
have you do feet together arms down to
your side put your arms down to your
side for me thank you all right so what
you're going to do is you're going to
imagine a line on the ground in front of
you it's a straight line okay go ahead
and place your left foot on that line
all right now place your right foot in
front of your left foot and just stay
like that for me okay like this well
nope not just yet that was that whole
don't start until I tell you to sorry
that's all right so feet together arms
down your side okay just place your left
foot on that line now place your right
foot heel to toe in front of your left
foot and just stay like that for me okay
so what I'm going to have you do is from
that position you're going to take so go
ahead get back in that position right so
left foot on the line right foot in
front of your left foot and just stay
right there for me okay okay so from
that position yes ma'am from that
position you're going to take nine Heel
To Toe steps along that line just like
this don't start until I tell you to but
just watch me okay one two yeah three
yeah heel the toe and then you're going
to go up to nine and then once you get
to nine you're going to Pivot off of the
lead foot with a small series of steps
just like this and you're going to turn
back off that lead foot well not pivot
but a small series of steps okay okay
and then from that place you're going to
return with another another nine Heel To
Toe steps back to where you started one
2 3 so on and so forth until you reach
nine okay so I just did three just to
show you but I'm going to have you do
nine yes ma'am so from so try and get
back in pos position that I told you to
so left foot on the line right foot in
front of your left foot just stay like
that for me just just stay uh yep okay
so just from right there you're going to
keep your arms down to your side you're
going to take those nine Heel To Toe
steps along that line like a but do you
want to do it down the slant I don't
really care you want to do it on the
sidewalk I really don't sidewalk sidew
yeah we can do it up on the sidewalk I
mean whatever y'all think I don't really
so it's up to you the sidewalk is level
ground so that'll work so don't keep
your arms down to your side though all
right so from right there you're going
well hang on hang on just a sec don't
don't start I to put my left foot out
yeah so put your left foot on the line
now place your right foot in front of
your left foot he toe all right so keep
your arms down to your side for me so
you're going to go ahead and do those
steps that I demonstrated for you you're
going to count them out loud for me look
down at your toe while you do it and
don't use your arms for balance okay and
I turn around and do the thing yes ma'am
yep and don't stop after you've started
okay count the steps out loud for me and
look down at your toe keep your arms
down to your side don't use them for
balance okay try not to grab onto the
wall either okay you understand the
instructions yes sir all right go ahead
and
begin one 2 3 4
5 6 7 8
9 1
2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 okay thank you very much all
right so we can stay up there on on the
level ground if you'd like um give me
just a second I just got to grab my cell
phone okay
just doing serious test make sure you sa
to
drive I
know I feel like I love you huh I don't
know I I feel like I like
you I'm a little sweaty for that I was
out directing traffic
all all y'all need a haircut I do need
hair I work
okay uh so from right there um you want
to take like one step back just so we're
not like on the ledge not against the
wall though just yeah just like right
there yeah that's perfect so what I'm
going to have you do is feet together
arms down to your side when I tell you
to begin you're going to take a foot of
your choice either left or right and
you're going to lift it 6 in off the
ground and point your toe outwards like
this and you're going to count 1,1 1,002
13 so on and so forth until I tell you
to stop okay you you understand the
instructions yeah okay so just keep your
arms down to your side don't be hopping
around try not to sway around and don't
use your arms for balance okay do you
understand the instructions yeah all
right you ready to begin yes all right
whenever you're
ready count out loud for me 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8
15 that's really hard for like I got you
I mean h i a a b like I'm not trying to
be okay all right you're good uh
okay what's up let me try again you want
to try again okay all right that's fine
let me try one more time sure so but I
really am not
that's all so feet together arms down
your side give me just a
second all right you ready to begin yeah
go
ahead count out loud for me do I have to
count yes ma'am one two 3
5 6
7 8
9 all right thank you okay uh let's
see
it's hard to like stand on the it's all
right uh so put your feet together arms
down your side I'm going do a little
thing with the pen again I'm going to
start up here and I'm going to do a
little circle around your face I'm going
to come in towards the bridge of your
nose I'm not going to touch your nose
though not going to give you a little
boot uh but I'm going to come close to
your nose all right well I'm going to
come close to your nose but I'm not
going to touch it okay so just follow
that with your eyes eyes only don't move
your head
okay
all right thank
you okay uh for this next one's super
super easy all I need to do feet
together arms down to your side you're
going to tilt your head back and you're
going to close your eyes when I tell you
to and I'm just going to have you
estimate the passing of 30 seconds
whenever you say go okay and then once
once you're done with 30 seconds you
just tilt your head forward open your
eyes and say I'm done okay okay so go
ahead and til your head back close your
eyes and do you understand the
instructions yes 30 seconds I got that
yeah you're just going to estimate the
passing in 30 seconds okay go ahead and
take your head back close your eyes and
then whenever you say go we'll start
go
done I have like I do hair dude it's
like 5 minutes I got to check your foils
girl like I have a 5 minute time block
so good sense of time don't sorry about
it oh you you're good okay I do all
right good yeah I mean you estim made 30
seconds so that's good okay okay um I'm
going be straight with you just need to
turn around yeah yes ma'am what you're
you're under arrest right now
okay go ahead and place your hands
behind your back put your palms against
each
other put your pals up against each
other you want M you want me I got
you
[Music]
all right right now you already being
pluss for driving on influence alcohol
okay right
let's go ahead and walk back over to my
car
okay I'm my car on the right over
there I don't think you have any pockets
on you
[Music]
do just go ahead and put your belly up
against here for me you you don't have
any pockets on you or anything like that
no I'm just going use the back of my
hand to sweep along your waistband just
make
sure all right
do you want your purse in your phone
where's your purse
at it's it is it in the front
seat it's like it's what color is it
it's it's like hippy looking like just
okay you just got your cell phone in
there this going to have phone listen
it's going to have phone numbers in
there for you to make your phone call
okay I'm so
it's okay so let's sit I'm going to grab
your purse okay so just you're good
you're good just take a seat for me okay
huh what's
up I'm not saying anything okay I I
didn't know if you were trying to talk
to me or
not all right um so I just got to read
you something okay Melissa how old are
you how old are
you
huh 31 31 okay all right Melissa the
state of Georgia has conditioned and
privileged to drive upon the highways of
the state upon your submission to State
administered chemical tests of your
blood breath urine or other bodily
substances for the purpose of
determining if you are under the
influence of alcohol or drugs if you
refuse this testing your Georgia
driver's license or privilege to drive
on the highways of the state will be
suspended for a minimum period of one
year I will not your refusal to submit
to blood or urine testing may be offered
into evidence against you at trial I
will not if you submit to testing and
the results indicate an alcohol
concentration of 0.08 G or more your
Georgia driver's license or privilege to
drive on the highways of the state may
be suspended for a minimum period of 1
year after first submitting to the
requested Sate test you're entitled to
additional chemical tests of your blood
breath urine or other bodily substances
at your own expense and from qualified
Personnel of your own choosing will you
submit to the state administ chemical
test of your
breath no it's a yes or no no okay I I
just got to ask okay read one more time
okay no I I have to so the state of
Georgia has conditioned your privilege
to drive upon the highways of the state
upon your submission to State
administered chemical tests of your
blood breath urine or other bodily
substances for the purpose of
determining if you are under the
influence of alcohol or drugs literally
ruining my if you refuse this testing
your Georgia driver's license or
privilege to drive on the highways
estate will be suspended for a minimum
period of one year your refusal to
submit to blood or urine testing may be
offered into evidence against you at
trial if you submit to testing and the
results indicate an alcohol
concentration of 0.08 G or more your
Georgia driver's license or privilege to
drive on the highways of the state may
be suspended for a minimum period of one
year after first submitting to the
requested state test you're entitled to
additional chemical tests of your blood
breath urine or other bodily substances
at your own expense and from qualified
Personnel of your own choosing will you
submit to the state administered
chemical test of your blood no okay
thank you ma'am this is your purse
correct
it
is I mean I don't really at this point
this it really fucking yes because
you'll need the phone number unless you
know by heart I know my husband's number
okay all right well you want this to go
with you then I would like it yes and I
would like for you to see if my phone's
in my PE I did where else will it be I
can please
okay you're literally
ruining all right Melissa you have the
right to remain silent anything you say
can Will abuse against you in a court of
law you have the right to talk to a
lawyer and have him or her present with
you while you're being questioned if you
cannot afford to hire a lawyer one will
be appointed to represent you before any
questioning if you wish you can decide
at any time to exercise these rights and
not answer any questions or make any
statements do you understand these
rights yeah okay do you want to talk to
me no what was
that no okay
is there enough AC in there for you no
all right do you want me to turn it up
no get this
okay I'll take
it yeah it's coming with us give us just
a second I don't know she might the
phone Blind Pig they checked it not in
here all
right
unless I missed a pocket or something I
me there was one pocket that had money
in it but I didn't
see phone
yeah your cell phone's not in here did
you leave it at the blind
Peg okay I can't do you think I really
can think right now like I can't hey I'm
just asking cuz I want you to I know
you're trying to be nice I get it I'm
being as nice as I can like I really
appreciate it I know y'all are doing
well you need but you also realiz I've
never done this ever in my life and this
is so I get you it's a learning lesson
that's it my dad is so it's a learning
lesson no it's well you're you're alive
exactly so that that is the absolute
best outcome I'm 31 years old well I
just worked one right before this and
the guy smashed into a tree so I'm glad
that that's not the case for you so
let's um the bo huh
I fucking hate myself all right I'm
going to go ahead and try and speed this
process up so you're not sitting here
all night okay please all right you want
a buckler in you want your seat belt on
no okay all
right um know
HB y'all know her husband's phone number
number he hasn't answered for you guys
yes he's on the way we have on the way I
I didn't I didn't hear that no that's
that's not what I'm talking
about
that you get I'm not I'm not arguing or
yelling with you way I'm so sorry you
had to come out here and do this you're
good I'm asking is if somebody can get
this car cuz I don't want to tow it Dad
I can't help you with um I want to maybe
tomorrow I I don't know that might have
to sit there okay we don't really have
anyone that we know that we can y'all
haven't talked to her husband at all I
have we might tomorrow the right way to
go um if you could give us the key to it
no I'm not going to say that if you
could give us the key to that car we can
tow it tomorrow baby baby I need you to
sit down and stop like we have too much
going for us I need you to act well we
can tow the car off tomorrow but not
tonight that car is going to have to sit
there we're going to have to tow it then
um that's okay we can't help you what's
up I got you I got you whenever you want
to talk when that gone I got you okay
are you guys good yeah I mean I wish we
could I've been through this though we
we' both been through this L don't play
this game I know I wish we could help
you but no it's okay I just want to make
sure cuz I was trying to help her so I
don't have to to the car we want but we
don't really have anyone that we I get
you well yeah I don't want you guys to
move it at all I was just asking if you
guys had somebody that could come get it
but that's okay um we're just going to
have to tow it but that's all get it but
we could actually have someone come get
it if you can actually wait 5 minutes
you have somebody or R's coming to get
us if she could maybe like drive it
home we literally live right on that
other Street I don't know I don't know
if it would sa for a lot of trouble yeah
sorry I really don't know I don't know
how inconvenient it's going to be for
her to get that um yeah it's all right
uh we'll we'll probably just end up to
it just to be on the safer side um but
uh I I appreciate it y'all I'm not
trying to hit nobody up R nobody's day
or anything like that it's just it it
sucks but I mean it is what it is I'm
glad y'all are safe and nobody got a car
accident or anything like that it's best
outcome so all right thank you guys I
appreciate it
absolutely what's that there's something
else huh were you talking about
something else on the radio I didn't
hear it oh I talk about
at um we'll do next line cuz they don't
have contact with her husband or said
that's not the right way to go or
something like that so I don't know
what's going on there but I ain't going
to dabble
yeah her name and I think yeah that's
this is okay yeah this is Melissa all
right and you have theirs
yeah yeah I'll get it back hey so he
knows when I can you know when I can
bail her out
right you know when I can build her out
yeah I'm I'm the arresting officer so so
what what do I need to know you know if
she's been arrest for dii before she's
never okay then she can get out tonight
tonight yeah okay uh she'll have to post
bail uh you're Lanna that is me all
right this D David yeah thank you yes
ma'am okay so we can get them out
tonight yeah um it'll be probably a few
hours um but she'll have to post bail
and then she'll be good to go does she
have your phone number yes we don't have
her phone that's okay that's my ride
does she does she know your number by
heart do you think you want do you want
to write it down for me David come here
we're leaving K's here he gave us our
IDs
back yeah he
just it's okay yeah everybody's good can
I write down one of y'all number you can
write my
name he's in respectful as fuck I know
he numbers for okay but David priest but
this is not what we dealt with last time
David priest what's your
number
yes sir I'm sorry no you get me it is
what it is no it's we got to no it's not
I never in Georgia I moved here 2 years
ago and like I I fell in love with this
girl at some shit at the end of the day
you have to get your shit right you know
whether you're the right the wrong at
the end day you to accept responsibility
we've both been the wrong I've been
arrested I have but I responsibility bro
like it's biggest thing um but I'm just
glad everybody's alive everybody's okay
I am too and and and I thank you sorry
for being no worries I mean I'm sorry I
really am I know how big of a dick that
is to deal with
oh it's my specialty huh
yeah right helping thank you you got it
we got it relax relax yeah still pled in
you're
welcome I know I'm trying to I am
relaxed I'm relaxed not I'm relaxed no
you're not if I was you guys I'd try to
sweep by you're not relax yes am you're
going to home you're going I home AOC in
the morning baby I hey I love you I'm
going to get you
out dude just get the fuck off of me
like get me the fuck
dude all
right I'm sorry no man you guys are good
just we'll see you guys you have a good
one man yep use well thank you
well fucking you ain't being too nice of
course
not why would I because I haven't been
bad to
you come on you going to blame this on
me really you know this ain't my fault
I'm just doing my
job like look at me I know
oh my get your hair out your
face I don't want to do this I've never
done this we don't have a choice right
now I don't
want all
right
over
here
there walking the other
way go ahead
and I mean come on be
nice I'm not being mean to
you huh what what' you say nothing okay
about to be me huh
because I get
itest you're going to push through it no
I'm not you you understand my literally
fucking murder me like fucking kill me
you're
alive matter literally what's
up yeah I got to print
it oh okay Co what
whatever I just got to PR the paperwork
cool whatever well I'm GL you back what
me in so you can make some money make
some money you think I get paid for
this think so no I get the same rate
that I always do well I glad you saw
that because literally I want to fucking
go
okay literally I rather kill myself to
my dad see me like
this would you like your dad have to see
like that no I wouldn't so I get that
yeah get I could you see why I'm like
hyperventilating a little
bit you know wondering where my husband
is yeah I get you it's really hard I'm
sure I'm not saying it's easy I'm just
saying you're going to be able to push
through
it yeah keep that my life it is and it
already has starting right
now is literally fucking up my it's a a
very large I can't work
tomorrow hey why
don't you're going to be out in a few
hours you're not just wake up and then
just go to work and act
like you're going to have a court date
but you're not staying
here and you're still
just let's just's just like this is so
embarassing like I legit cannot believe
this is happening to me like I really
can't
let
right here for me please